bonjour monsieur champagne
bonsoir
Aujourd'hui plaisir de vous retrouver
expliquez-nous l'autre et concrètement
cette initiative de technologie
aéronautique durable du Canada à quoi ça
va servir les sommes que tawa annoncent
aujourd'hui
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
peu la grande messe de l'aviation on
s'appelle ça le salon du Bourget à Paris
alors tous les acteurs de l'industrie
sont réunis et c'est important parce que
vous savez le Canada une place de choix
après Toulouse s'y attendent c'est
vraiment Montréal qui est la plateforme
on a fait une annonce de 350 millions
pour dire nous on veut continuer avec
les leaders dans le domaine de
l'aviation mais l'aviation durable parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on parle au grand
donneur d'or ce que les gens parlent
aujourd'hui c'est comment on peut rendre
tout le secteur de l'aviation plus
durable c'est-à-dire plus vert et ça
nous si vous savez c'est important parce
que comme on est un leader l'idée
derrière ce fond là ça va être un fond
panne national qui va permettre aux
petites et moins d'entreprise aussi de
collaborer parce que c'est un fond qui
va permettre de partager si vous savez
un peu le risque de ces nouvelles
technologies là parce que ça va être de
donner une aviation c'est assez
conservateur donc il y a pas vraiment
une initiative pour aller plus loin dans
les nouveaux matériaux dans les
terburants durable mais là l'idée moi si
je veux positionner comme on le fait
dans le domaine des batteries comment on
le fait dans le domaine des vues que les
trucs comment se positionne pour les
jamais prendre 50 prochaines années et
c'était ça la grande annonce aujourd'hui
au salon du Bourget monsieur champagne
mais par contre vous savez le Bourget
souvent on a une liste de contrats très
concrets de partenariats qui sont
annoncés là dans le cadre de ce que vous
annoncez c'est une enveloppe 350
millions de dollars mais on n'a pas idée
des projets précis par exemple qui
pourraient être porté par l'industrie
est-ce que vous avez des cibles à cette
à cet égard là
tout à fait la première parce que vous
savez par exemple ce qu'on a Montréal
c'est prête à Whitney on a fait aussi
c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'aviation durable mais c'est aussi
c'est la propulsion hybride donc ça veut
dire toute la question des moteurs parce
qu'on est conscient qu'un jour on
devrait aller vers d'autres technologies
donc ça c'est un des vecteurs où on va
l'autre c'est un nouveau des carburants
durables et l'autre c'est nouveau
vraiment de l'architecture et
l'infrastructure des avions on a déjà
une place de choix parce qu'au Québec au
Canada on connaît déjà ça mais l'idée
c'est comment nous parce que l'idée ici
quand on était au Bourget c'est de
disposé comme chef de fil alors cette
annonce là ne positionne en avant nous
on sait où l'industrie va nous on va
être les leaders de ça puis je peux vous
dire qu'il y a un peu d'effervescence
parce que les commandes sont en rose
dans l'industrie les évidemment les
revenus des entreprises aussi être une
période difficile vous direz le moral
est en haut généralement dans
l'industrie et puis je pense une bonne
nouvelle parce qu'il y a des centaines
de milliers de travailleurs en
travaillant ce qui nous regardent qui
font partie de sa distribue on veut
amener des jeunes aussi dans l'industrie
donc c'est important de leur donner une
vision obtenir c'est ce qu'on faisait
aujourd'hui vous avez évoqué les
carburants durable monsieur champagne
est-ce qu'on peut penser que le Canada
peut devenir et rester un leader parce
que ça se bouscule il y a les Chinois il
y a Singapour il y a les Pays-Bas la
France qui sont dans la course
l'administration Biden vise la
production de 3 milliards de litres
d'ici 2030 est-ce qu'il y a un risque
que le Canada se fasse damer le pion au
chapitre des carburants durables
bah écoutez il faut travailler ensemble
je parlais par exemple avec le ministre
Gabin aujourd'hui j'ai rencontré le
Grand PDG d'Airbus Guillaume Faury on
est en train de se positionner il faut
aller vite il faut avoir aussi du volume
parce que c'est un domaine qui avancer
rapidement mais vous avez raison c'est
pour ça le 350 000 aussi c'est de
développer des nouvelles technologies
parce qu'on s'y connaît en matière de
carburant au Canada donc l'idée c'est de
nous faire partie de ce groupe là qui va
développer les nouveaux standards les
nouvelles règles autour de cette
carburant là et nous permettent d'être
évidemment dans une position de leader
dans le monde alors aujourd'hui on fait
le tour des grands joueurs on leur dit
qu'on sera là et puis évidemment c'est
pour ça qu'on investit ouais j'insiste
là-dessus par exemple parce que il y a
quelques jours là ou deux semaines à peu
près le Conseil canadien des carburants
d'aviation durable ou a demandé de
l'argent à Ottawa quelle part de
l'argent aujourd'hui pourrait servir à
ses producteurs là par exemple
c'est un enveloppe globale pour les
nouvelles technologies et d'abord je
salue leur travail je peux vous dire
qu'on parle à beaucoup d'acteurs à
travers le monde dans ce domaine là
aujourd'hui on était avec les grands
donneurs d'ordre demain on va parler à
d'autres gens qui sont dans le domaine
du raffinage parce que c'est comme deux
industries qui doivent se rejoindre
alors je voudrais qu'on est au cœur de
cette discussions là et je vous dirai
l'enveloppe d'aujourd'hui va
certainement permettre c'est pas juste
les grands joueurs qu'on veut on veut
aussi développer les PME qui pourraient
s'intéresser à cette industrie là parce
que pour savoir si l'industrie de
l'aviation l'aéro spatiale c'est pas
juste Montréal je vous donne des
exemples de machin William les plus la
plus grande PME fait partie du domaine
de Larousse faciale alors nous l'idée
c'est comme on peut aider les PME les
milliers d'emplois à travers le pays la
meilleure façon c'est de se positionner
dans le futur puis les carburants
durables évidemment font partie le
financement que vous annoncez monsieur
champagne répond à une demande de
l'industriant les joueurs souhaitaient
avoir cette appui pour favoriser
l'innovation favoriser la recherche et
le développement or les fonds seront
gérés en quelque sorte par l'industrie
est-ce que vous avez fixé des sites pour
s'assurer que ça donne des résultats
c'est un nouveau modèle je suis content
de vous poser la question parce
qu'effectivement souvent vous savez les
gouvernements arrivent avec des
programmes c'est plus ou moins adapté
aux besoins d'industrie cette fois-là ce
qu'on a fait on est allé voir l'Indus on
a dit qu'est-ce que vous voulez comment
on peut vous aider avec l'objectif de
dire nous on va être leader alors dites
nous vous spécialiste de l'industrie
comment vous voulez faire ça c'est notre
argent comme canadien comme canadienne
on est prêt à vous en remettre une
partie pour devenir leader ça va être
géré par l'industrie pour des projets
qui sont ciblés par l'industrie comme je
disais 4 vecteurs qui sont importants
dans l'architecture la structure des
avions donc 1 et 2 ensuite de ça on part
du carburant durable et troisièmement
par la propulsion hybride où on a déjà
une avance avec fraternité évidemment
l'orgueil qui est déjà chef de fil dans
le domaine alors moi je vous dis on a
répondu je pense que je le dis pour ceux
qui nous écoutent là c'est un modèle à
suivre je pense parce que répondre aux
besoins de l'industrie c'est vraiment un
programme par l'industrie pour
l'industrie et là nous on est partenaire
là-dedans mais je pense c'est une bonne
façon de faire justement pour bien
cibler les besoins plutôt que d'arriver
avec un programme général il pourrait ou
non fonctionner pour l'industrie en tout
cas ça s'inscrit dans une des grandes
thématiques du salon ou du Bourget cette
année la décarbonation de l'industrie
l'aviation c'est à peu près 3 % de
toutes les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans le monde mais il y a des
régimes de compensation auxquels le
Canada adhère qui est volontaire est-ce
que les les États devraient serrer la
vis monsieur champagne pour la
décarbonation se fasse plus rapidement
pas deux choses il y a la réglementation
mais il y a aussi la technologie parce
que je travaillais aujourd'hui avec les
grands donneurs d'ordre par exemple je
vous parle de je parle de d'Airbus qui
est chez nous Airbus c'est justement un
de ceux qui disent nous on va aller même
plus rapidement alors c'est là où on va
être avec eux parce que la meilleure
façon il semble de décaler l'industrie à
court terme c'est vraiment avec les
carburants durables alors c'est là nous
on mise pour travailler avec eux les
constructeurs les compagnies aériennes
les gens qui font du raffinage fait au
coeur un peu de cette industrie là on a
encore du travail à faire je vous dirais
même c'est interdit vous l'avez dit il y
a une course mais nous on va être dans
la course puis j'espère qu'on va gagner
parce que évidemment notre industrie
vous avez quand on est le Canada au
Bourget tout le monde veut nous parler
c'est facile venir ici là vous n'avez
pas besoin de faire grand chose tout le
monde veut nous parler bon alors je vais
vous laisser aller discuter avec vos
interlocuteurs monsieur champagne merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
merci de m'avoir invité merci bonne
soirée pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI